[Music]
there we go can you imagine that i mean
this is
this is the way to spend your time hey
it's evan carmichael and like warren
buffett says you want to associate with
people that are better than you are i
mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and that's why i create
these videos to help you associate with
people doing bigger things than you
need motivation watching top 10 to
believe nation top
high for my 10 10.99
what did you aspire to do what did you
aspire to become a very wealthy person
would you want to be buying a stocks
would you want to buy companies what was
your aspiration in those early days i i
loved i loved just analyzing securities
i just spent
hours and hours and hours just i kept
turning the pages of moody's which
instead of going you know you had no
internet then anything else so you had
two sources of information moody's and
standard and poor's
and
we happened to have these sets of movies
they were about in aggregate probably
about 8 000 pages
about five different manuals and
i went through those page by page
and well it must have been exciting uh
oh
yeah
it's a little strange i mean you know i
i actually went to amazon
a few years ago and i found an old 1951
moody's now everybody else is going
there for playboy magazine but i'm
ordering the old moody's uh you've got a
strange guy here
rule number two own stocks you're
joining us on a day when we have watched
the stock market continue to set new
highs the s p uh the russell and the
nasdaq the dow's not far off and the
question we always ask you is do stocks
look expensive to you at these prices
well they are definitely if you had your
choice between buying and holding a
30-year bond for 30 years or holding
a basket of american stocks
there's just no question you're going to
do better owning stocks so it it's
it's more attractive than considerably
more attractive than fixed income
securities that doesn't mean they're
gonna go up or down tomorrow or next
week or next year
but
over time
a bunch of businesses that are earning
high returns on capital are going to
beat a bond that's fixed at
roughly 3 for 30 years
and i i
it's not my field of especially but but
actually they look stocks generally
which are their businesses they're
american businesses 30 trillion worth of
them and they look cheaper than than uh
uh
generally real estate you're sitting
with some cash in your buggy you've had
savings and the question is what do you
do with it you can buy a duplex next
door and rent it out to people and do
fine over time or
you can you can buy a small piece of
farmland or something of this order or
you can put it into something fixed
income bonds or
bank deposits or whatever it may be
and
stocks if you look at american equities
american business is earning a lot of
money relative to the capital put in
and the reason stocks are worth a whole
lot more than they were 20 years ago or
50 years ago or 100 years ago is
companies have plowed back part of the
earnings with a bond you get it all out
in interest you know you get your three
percent or whatever it is and that's
what you have with stocks you get a
maybe a three percent dividend but
they're plowing money back or they're
repurchasing shares or doing something
and
over time that just makes a huge
difference rule number three have fun i
was wondering what is your definition of
success and what has been your largest
non-business success in life
well we played ping pong against a
nine-year-old girl in san francisco
two weeks ago
her name's ariel know how many points
did you think she got up bill got more
points off her than i did
i thought i was pretty good
and this little nine-year-old is
disgusting she should have been in bed
she totally cleaned us
[Music]
that was that was a little humiliating
rule number four buy when the price is
right i'd rather
buy a an attractive business
than buy our own stock
at its intrinsic business value if our
stock gets well below that
i've still got this strong and i can do
both fortunately but
but
why how an executive
can
pay
say we're going to spend 10 billion
dollars buying stock and then not paying
the attention of the price at which they
buy it they wouldn't buy any other
business that way uh
and and
so we're price sensitive on it on the
other hand when the price is right
there's no easier way to make money for
your shareholders
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five persist you rejected by
harvard you went to columbia business
school and then you met the man who you
really idolized ben graham and when you
took his class was he as great as you
had thought he was going to be he really
was he only he only taught
one semester one class i mean he came up
from wall street and taught this class
uh that's the reason i went to columbia
and uh
he
i knew what he i knew i'd already read
all the books and everything so i but it
was inspirational just to be around him
and i i it made a real difference in my
life so when you um
graduated you wanted to go work for him
and his firm and then he rejected you uh
for an interesting reason uh in those
days i understand that there were jewish
firms and non-jewish firms and his was a
jewish firm and you weren't jewish so he
said because you weren't jewish he
didn't hire you is that right that's
true he's and i i was ready to convert
bulimia
i i think they might have felt a little
phony at the time so
i uh but it was it was true that there
were very few firms in wall street that
would hire jews at that time and then
only employed five or six people but he
told me to the extent that they had
were able to employ five or six people
they really felt that the jews could not
get into
most jobs in wall street and that they
they were going to employ only jews so
you moved back for a while to um uh
nebraska but then he ultimately changed
his mind and you went to work for ben
graham i kept pestering him yeah i made
a real best of myself rule number six
know when to leave you entered the
municipal bond insurance business at an
interesting time and i think
subsequently had some second thoughts
about it and i would love to know your
feelings on that industry now especially
given where certain cities and
commonwealths are yeah we uh we we did
start guaran guaranteeing the municipals
uh five years ago or so at the time we
were getting
premiums of
probably
over three percent
averaging over three percent sometimes
four or five percent
uh and
in almost all cases we had other
municipal bond insurers that came ahead
of us so we were
second to pay third to pay forth to pay
sometimes and getting this pretty fat
rate and then the rates went down
dramatically and uh
for the same risk
within a year to
we would have probably only been getting
a quarter of the premium and
you know insurance is attractive at one
price and it's not attractive another
price so when rates
when rates leave us you know we leave
the business
basically and that's what we did if
rates were high enough
uh are appropriate in our view as to the
risk involved
we would insure municipals again i mean
we're selective about it
but we
we just weren't getting paid enough rule
number seven make money with money what
really gives the low rates
to the very rich like me is the
the low tax on dividends and capital
gains if you take these rich people that
the irs singles out from 1992
they've almost had a tenfold increase in
capital gains they've had a tenfold
increase almost in dividends and those
those are taxed at 15 percent and
there's no payroll tax on it now the
payroll tax accounts for almost as much
revenue to the government as the income
tax it's it's close
uh 800 billion plus on payroll taxes
last year and about 900 billion on on
income taxes that's where the money
comes from in washington
and
they don't get any payroll tax to speak
up on my income i you know i've got my
tax return here you can take a look at
them in a moment and
they you know they get i get taxed on up
to a hundred thousand and and uh and my
super rich friends get taxed up to a
hundred thousand and that tax hits the
people in my office very very hard often
they have a spouse working so they get
taxed on up to two hundred thousand
dollars that payroll tax and that's it
this year we've had a waiver of two
points but that's normally at fifteen
point three percent that alone is higher
than the tax rate on capital gains or
dividends you point out that the average
tax rate for people in your audience in
your average rate for people in your
office is 36 percent of taxable income
36 percent and nobody's below 33
and incidentally the lowest income
person in the office is higher than the
33 they don't have the low rate so from
33 to 41 they range and they average 36
and i'm in there with a fat 17.4 i think
it is and why is that well it taxes if
you make money with money
you get taxed very at very low rates 15
percent dividends in capital gains no
payroll tax
if you make money with muscle or hard
work or sweat of your brow you get taxed
at rates that
move on up and
most of the people the middle class gets
taxed
at rates of either 15 or 25 on their
income tax but then they get really hit
hard on the payroll tax and that's what
brings the
rates in our office up to an average of
36 percent if you leave me out rule
number eight help people we admire so
much your legacy and philanthropy and
your children's philanthropy i'd love to
just hear your philosophy around that
well my friend charlie said
who gave away somebody the other day
says it won't do me much good where i'm
going yeah so the you know i've got
everything in life i want
and uh
you know it uses a very tiny percentage
of my resources so i have a some stock
certificates that i bought 40 or 50
years ago down in a safe deposit box
and they have no utility to me
they they can't buy anything for me that
i need or want i mean uh i can go down
and fondle them occasionally or
something of the sort but but other than
that they're just pieces of paper
they have enormous utility for other
people yeah and particularly views
wisely they have no utility for me so
why in the world should i sit there and
let them sit in the box
and uh
you know i have never given away a penny
that
has affected my life in any way shape or
form there's people that this sunday
will drop five dollars into a collection
plate and makes the difference between
whether they go out for dinner or
something or go to a movie
i've never done any of that but
if you have this incredible surplus
and
in our giving pledge we we we call these
we only call on people with a billion
you know and i'm only asking them for
half so i i said on my when they turned
me down i say you know i'm going to
write a book on how to live on 500
million because there's apparently a big
need for this
i i found i could live on 500 million so
all the rest had a lot less and all the
rest is surplus and why not do you know
if it can provide vaccines or education
or whatever it may be or a better life
for women i mean why not use it number
nine be objective how can you tell when
a company is doing a bad job
repurchasing
you have to be able to figure out how to
value this properly it's easier than
you're making it sound yeah
the truth is if you look back
and i was director of the company but
coca-cola kept repurchasing their shares
at a time when it didn't make sense if
you look at it uh in the years earlier
they just they
they had a terrifically good idea
of repurchasing when the com company
only had a market value of you know in
the in
less than 10 billion and and they bought
a lot of stock and they were aggressive
about it and but uh
uh they fell in love with the idea and
and i was
a director
at the time and and and but they're one
of many i mean the same thing happened
to gillette uh to a degree
it's interesting uh
uh
sometimes it's
difficult for ceos to be objective about
their own stock price and they think
this bet
they think the higher itself the better
you know and and uh
and it's a fine way to feel except if
you're repurchasing it and you
repurchase it the price is up to the sky
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips
is have confidence in leaders confidence
is an important thing sure it is and
there was a damage to confidence based
on what happened in washington
charlie i own stock in a lot of
companies
if i get upset about the management you
know what they're doing do i lose
confidence yes do i feel different about
investing with them yes i mean
i mean you you want to have you've got
to have confidence in your leaders i
mean we went into world war ii with
confidence our leaders you know i mean
that it's vital it looked like we were
losing the war for six months but we
never lost confidence in our in our
leaders and it's we you have to believe
in them and they have to give you reason
to believe in them now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think are
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the good deed of the day this is
something new i believe that you're able
to serve and it feels so good to do
something nice for somebody else so good
deed of the day put down in the comments
one thing that you need help with that
you're working on you'd love some
support or guidance on and then two go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well
you invest most of your money i guess in
the united states yeah have you
increasingly been investing outside
particularly in the emerging markets or
you're not as comfortable investing in
the emerging markets i'm comfortable in
any place i understand the business well
and to some extent the rules that they
operate and where i've got the right
management and so i we will buy a
business you know in any one of 40
countries tomorrow if it's the right
kind of business uh but most businesses
i hear about are in the united states
they think of berkshire here we're not
we're on the radar screen here to a
greater extent than around the world i
have constructed a business that fits me
it's kind of crazy to spend your life
painting if you're painting a subject
you don't want to look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business
on an unlimited canvas in a way
it's a different sort of place
i work with great group of people that
make my life very easy and take good
care of me
[Music]
we have 25 people in the office and if
you go back it's the exact same 25 the
exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire
we don't have a public relations
department investor relations we don't
have a general counsel we don't have a
human relations department we just don't
go for anything that people do just as a
matter of form
it's exactly the life i like go back to
when i started my partnership in 1956
that berkshire came out of
there were seven people sitting there at
a table
having dinner
relatives primarily and i said here's
the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little
half page what i call the ground rules
and i want you to read these
and if you feel okay about that
about the interaction what the
expectations are and all of that sort of
thing then we'll join forces and if you
don't it's fine other people have you
know but we don't we shouldn't be
partners i mean you know if i'm gonna
have a partnership with somebody i want
to be compatible it is you know and
when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that so by my actions
and my communications and everything i
want to attract the people
that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away costco was
built
sal price who started the price club
that thing
he sat down and figured out the customer
he didn't want
and he set up a system that would keep
away the customer he didn't want who did
not want he didn't want somebody buying
a quart of milk with somebody behind
them with a
with a basket of 200 worth of goods
waiting for that so we put in a
membership fee and by putting in a
membership page he killed all the
drop-in business the business that
belongs to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire
to to keep out people who have
expectations about us that are different
than ours i mean
good for them and i hope they find
somebody they said but
if you're going to run a church
you want you want your seats to be
filled by people that are generally want
to listen to your form of religion and
you don't want it to change every week
and say gee i need a new group and i'll
go out and talk to a bunch of investors
and get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church there's a million
645 000 or so a equivalent shares and
those are the seats and i want them
occupied by people that are on the same
page i am i was lucky that i got started
early i mean it always helps if you get
started early and
and my dad happened to be in an
investment business so i would go down
his office on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in in a
sense and that that helped a lot and and
i was always fascinated by them i knew
what i wanted to do early and i think
that's a that's a huge advantage too
and then you don't need you don't need a
lot of brains in this business i mean
i've always said if you got an iq of 160
give away 30 points to somebody else
because you don't need an investment
what you do need is emotional stability
you have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that when the market's good
if you feel good don't if you feel bad
you should probably do it right
but uh how uh how how did you uh what
what was that extra thing where uh so
many will acknowledge that and yet we
saw in the current crisis they they
panicked why you went into seemingly uh
potential disasters like ge and goldman
sachs
i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just
it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of confidence you know that
tom watson said it best he said you know
he said he said i'm no genius but i'm
smart in spots and i stay around those
spots well i try and stay around those
spots and i i just don't have a a
problem if if uh if somebody says you
know you're wrong on something i just i
go back and look at the facts and and
i think that i think that really is much
more important frankly than having a few
points of iq or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
if somebody told me 10 years ago what
was going to happen the next 10 years we
could have made a lot of money in the
bond market together you know but but
it's there's always a reason afterwards
tomorrow's paper will say stocks went
down today because of you know but they
didn't they didn't write it this
morning's paper stocks are going to go
down today
you have to know what you
don't know and you have to make sure
that what you don't know isn't all
important i mean you know if there's
four boxes there you want to get to what
is
knowable
and and and and and and which
uh is favorable
and
there's things that
you'll miss out on because they belong
in other three
boxes one of which will be favorable
another one the favorable and
uh the fact that you're missing out on
90 of the stuff doesn't really make any
difference if the ten percent you do is
right shortly after i met bill gates
bill's dad asked each of us to write
down on a piece of paper one word that
would best describe what it helped us
the most bill and i without any
collaboration at all he wrote the word
focus
well focus has always been
a strong part of my
personality if i get interested in
something i get really interested
if i get interested in the new subject i
want to read about it i want to talk
about it and i want to meet people that
are involved in it well i look at a lot
of figures just in connection with our
businesses i uh
i like to get numbers
so so i i'm getting reports in
weekly in some businesses uh uh that but
that doesn't tell me what the economy is
going to do six months from now or three
months from now it tells me what's going
on now with our businesses uh
uh and
it really doesn't make any difference in
what i do today in terms of buying
stocks or buying businesses what those
numbers tell me they're interesting but
they're not they're not guides to me
if we buy a business we're going to hold
it forever so we're going to have good
years bad years in between years maybe a
disastrous year or something here and
and
uh
we care a lot about the price we do not
care about the next 12 months economic
predictions just don't enter into our
decisions charlie munger my partner i
in
you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction we make business
predictions about what individual
businesses will do over time
and we compare that to what we have to
pay for
but we have never said yes
to something because we thought the
economy was going to do well in the next
year or two years and we've never said
no to anything
because we were right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right well
i've i've said many times that that
if you get to
be 65 or 70
and later and and the people that you
want to have love you actually do love
you
you're a success i've never seen anybody
that reaches that age i mean i'm not
talking about somebody that's in extreme
poverty or pain or something but i've
never seen anybody that if they have a
lot of people
that that love them that is other than
happy and i've seen some very very
wealthy people that they give
testimonial interest to and name schools
after and everything nobody nobody loves
them i was sort of wired for capital
allocation and being wired for capital
allocation a couple hundred years ago in
nebraska wouldn't have been a thing
uh and and even now being born in
various parts of the world i wouldn't
have been much but here i was in this
soon-to-be very rich capitalistic system
and and it just so happened that what i
did paid off enormously in a market
system like we have and i if i'd had a
talent in some other area that was way
less commercial i mean i would have i
would have had a good time doing it but
it wouldn't have paid off like this but
of course jay said it perfectly when he
talked about
you know he's in the recording for
himself and the money comes afterwards i
mean i
i get to do what i love i mean and
it doesn't get any luckier than that if
if you can spend your lifetime and i'm
80 now and doing things you love every
single day i mean i would be doing what
i did what i do now and i would have
done it in the past if the payoff had
been in seashells or sharksteen or
anything else
if you can go to work every morning i
tap dance to work you know and i come
down and i every day is exciting i like
to sit and think
and i spent a lot of time doing that and
sometimes it's pretty unproductive but
but
i i find it enjoyable to to think about
particularly about about business or
investment problems they're easy it's
it's the human problems that are the
tough ones
sometimes there aren't any good answers
with human problems there's almost
always a good answer with money i've got
this rule you know the first rule is
don't lose in the second rule is never
forget the first rule so it really isn't
so much having a lot of brilliant
decisions it's just not really having
some terrible ones and and and frankly i
did learn from ben graham how to avoid
ever having any disasters and
investments
it wasn't that you were going to come up
with the very smartest thing but if you
never have any
any significant losses
you know some singles and doubles will
produce a lot of runs before you get
through you're lucky
in life if you can find your passion i
tell the students you know what you may
have to take a job or two you get you
got to eat but
never give up searching for the job
that's your passion try to find the job
that you would have if you were
independently rich that's the job i have
and when you find that job the job that
causes you to be excited every day
and forget about the pay
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that my partner charlie
is 89 and we were talking about that
this weekend you know i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living
does not equate the standard of living
and the standard of living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside i
love to ride around in a private plate i
will totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i could live on
easily live on a hundred thousand
dollars a year and it and i wouldn't
live i wouldn't live better
if i had eight houses if i hadn't you
know a 400-foot yacht or anything of the
sword i've i've been on
400-foot yachts and i've been a lot of
fancy houses but i'm in a house that i
bought
55 years ago
it's
warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer it has everything i wanted plus
it has all kinds of good memories you
know my kids have good thoughts about it
i can't imagine living any better i paid
thirty one thousand five hundred dollars
for it i could pay 31 million for a
house the most important thing
uh
aside from the things i've talked about
already is it's really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are i mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when
obviously you can't pick your parents
they're going to have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you
who you
who you admire who you who who you want
to copy and the most important for most
people in terms of that decision is
their spouse it's also important in
terms of a partner in business but the
partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's that'll that's
better than you are when you get to my
age you will not measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got i can guarantee you that
you'll you'll all do fine on money
anyway i mean uh you know think about it
seven hours a day
you know
you're in a bed you've got exactly the
same mattress i've got if you don't
listen to it the furniture mark you know
i mean so so that when we're on a parody
i can't i can't outdo you you know in
terms of my sleeping enjoyment you can
you can match it by by buying this
mattress which we'll give you a special
price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
need a dairy queen particularly if
you're in my position because we own it
but but we eat at mcdonald's and burger
king and and when i leave here i'll stop
by a fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car up till about a year ago
you know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it you know we dress more
or less the same i mean i pay more for
my clothes but they look cheap when i
put them on so we're really
we're on a parody yeah so so the money
isn't going to be that big a deal
everybody in this country is going to
you know that with the intelligence this
group has the energy you have you're
going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say
that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean you know so i won't i don't want
i'm not short changing it i'm just
saying you can't do too much about that
but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many
and extent whether it's the people you
want
at 70 or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end i
mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love i mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you can buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get to be you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
you've got a lot of money it'd be more
fun to just write out a check for a
million dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way and in
fact it the only way is to be is to be
lovable and you know i've got this
friend
who uh
who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she's still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself
in determining who she really trusts his
friends the one question in her mind is
would they hide me
now when you get to be 70
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
you've had a successful life
i know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them i mean they
they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know
they they don't have anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh my friend
tom murphy at campus cities tv i mean
dozens of people would hide murph you
know
all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know
that
ben graham a lot of people would have my
dad it would have had a number and then
like i say that i can i can tell you
people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and the kids may put up
with them and hope they don't change
their will or something but the truth is
that nobody would hide them and if
you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life by
far the best investment you can make is
in yourself i mean that for example
communication skills i tell the students
that come that
they're going to
graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that if
they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least 50 percent
and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get
get both your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i take it a shorter course
now in terms of my talking later on but
it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from everything you do learn is
cumulative i mean that doesn't mean that
industries stay good forever or
businesses stay good forever but but
learning to think about business models
what i learned at 20 is useful to me now
what i learned at 25 is useful to me now
and so it's not it's not so it's not a
field that
changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics i mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager you know if you know what makes
a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and
i don't think i can win every game you
know somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chess so i don't play bobby fischer
chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at all of you in this room have the
brains to do extremely well in life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it you get
your full
potential or do you get 100 horsepower
or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can
hold you back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room if you
did have a lack of education
if you didn't have a chance to get a
decent education in life it wouldn't
make any difference what that potential
was because you'd never unlock it
but the second most important thing
and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we
hire people we look for three qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence and we look for energy
but if they don't have the first one
integrity the other two will kill you
because if you're hiring somebody
without integrity you really want to be
dumb and lazy don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing about
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump or the color of
your hair very easily but you can
elect
to have integrity that matches anybody
else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have uh you will get an
extraordinary result and you'd be very
foolish to sell me ten percent of
yourself for fifty thousand on the other
hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part go
unused i do tell them
those students you know that
if i gave you a car and it'd be the only
car you're getting the rest of your life
you take care of it like you can't
believe any scratch you'd fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage and do all these things
and you get exactly one mind of one and
one body in this world and
and you can't start taking care of it
when you're 50 by that time you'll rush
it out if you haven't done anything so
you you should just really make sure
that you
just remember that you just got one mind
and body to get through life with and to
do the most with it one of the things
you do in your annual report which has
become a classic is you will discuss
what went wrong
like dexter and what you and how
and and and what you learned from it
tough tough to do well it's it's it's
very important to recognize mistake i
mean
if if someone but it goes around and
says you know i never made a mistake i
mean you quit listening to them
you know they're in the dream world so
so
facing up to it uh it's it's a little
like in in in terms of discussing issues
you should be able to discuss the other
fellows position just as well as you can
discuss your own so i mean that's part
of thinking well and and certainly part
of making good decisions in business is
recognizing the poor decisions you've
made and and why they were poor and and
and
that doesn't mean you never do the same
thing i mean it because sometimes it was
a freak situation but but i have made
lots of mistakes i'm going to make more
mistakes
but
you know babe ruth struck out a lot of
times i mean it's the name of the game
that you do it you don't want to expect
perfection in yourself you want to
strive to do your best but but it's too
demanding to expect perfection in
yourself and it does some good to
recognize them and not start trying to
go around kidding people about them what
other habits did you cultivate in your
20s and your 30s that you now see as
being foundational to your success as a
business person
well i
i knew a lot
about what i do
uh when i was 20. i mean i i i really
read a lot and and
i aspired to learn everything that i
could about the subject so
intellectually i knew a lot
i did not know a lot about human
behavior i mean that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's it's very
important to understand people and uh i
say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy
or or you could be given 10 of the
future earnings of one person that you
know among
everybody you know now are you going to
pick the person that's the smartest i'm
going to pick the person that can dance
the best or that can run the fastest or
anything like that that's the right
height no anything no no
you're gonna you're gonna pick the
person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and when you look at all of
the qualities that you admire in other
people which would cause you to pick
that person say to yourself which of
those qualities can't i have myself
because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper who is the person that you
admire the most or like the best why do
i like them and just write down and then
say which of these can i do myself and
the truth is you can do them and then
you also if you really want to carry it
to the next extreme you pick the person
you dislike the most and why do you
dislike that person you know and you
know they always
they're never fair about things
basically they always claim more credit
than they're doing everything and write
down those qualities and say if you
dislike that some other person why in
the world would you want to have those
yourself so you just get rid of those
and it's a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick your best friend you know
that you would have the same qualities
as a general matter as a one piece of
specific finance
financial advice
i would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at eighteen or
twenty percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20 over time you know if
you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life
uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in
they run up bills they can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and uh they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before and they owe a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest let alone
pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but uh
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and
i will guarantee you if you run a big
credit card that you will be in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of uh your financial situation on
the other hand if you get ahead of the
game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're
people owe you money or equities owe you
ownership uh you'll be way out of the
game compared to paying it uh
being always being paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it you
don't need 150 iq to do what i do thank
god you know you don't need 140 you know
835 you may need 115 or something like
that and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball you have to you have to swing
at pitches that you you don't even
necessarily like particularly after the
count gets to two strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but
it's a marvelous game to be in because
there are no called strikes and you can
simply wait for that one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price or you like the people running the
business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime how do you
deal with failure and what's your advice
to young entrepreneurs like me in this
case especially with regards to failure
and how to approach it yeah well if
you fail you really do dust yourself off
and you know get right back in i mean
you're going to fail at some things uh
uh
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out uh you
know
fairly significant number of people get
divorced i mean you know that's a very
big decision to have turn out badly but
uh
i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history and
you'll everybody
fails at some things i mean you know
particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just knowing about whatever it may be
businesses uh but you know it it is not
fatal i mean if you're healthy and
you live in this particular living in
this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was when i got
out of the university of nebraska you
know and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you traveled on the train and so i spent
10 hours going there and this fellow
looked at me and about 10 minutes he
said you know forget it bell
and now i got to go back on the train 10
hours and think
what am i going to tell my dad i wanted
to tell my dad i mean my dad always told
me i could do anything and everything
now i've just got just gotten turned
down uh you know but it turned out that
one of the best things ever happened to
me because then i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact
it probably even affected who i married
because i took a one-year course at
columbia and said two years at harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time
almost everything in my life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually it's turned into a success
i mean it
it the world isn't over you know
if you have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but but
the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and you know
you've got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know
the world isn't over yet you know you
just go out
and find somebody else i got
an awful lot of good advice from my dad
and and he didn't he didn't lay it on me
i mean he just
you know you you picked it up from him
but there was never any of this you know
do this do that
type of thing at all but but
i think he really taught me that it's
more important
uh
in terms of what's on your inner score
card than your outer score card i mean
some people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what what
the world's going to think of this or
that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're going to have a pretty
happy life and i think the people that
strive too much for the outer scorecard
sometimes find that it's a little hollow
when they get all through i should
mention one thing about reading uh
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than any other
student i i lived there practically but
you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
because of
that librarian directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that
it's the chance i i
i read about one-fifth the pace that
bill does but i still spend five or six
hours a day reading i mean it's just you
can learn so much i particularly love
biography just uh you know to be able
to live the lives of these people that
have been
seeing so extraordinary the lessons and
the you know the discouragements they
face just everything about it so i just
you can't get enough of reading how do
you decide what you invest your time and
money in
yeah well i i i like to find
businesses that have good economics now
what what are good economics well good
economics are a business that has
some kind of a moat around it
that makes its product or its service or
its location or something
a little more
desirable than to the customer than any
other sort of comparable product
uh
you know the number one candy bar in the
last 30 or 40 years has been snickers
people don't fool around with different
candy bars they fool around with
different
length dresses they fool around you know
with all kinds of things but they don't
fool around with candy bars because they
figure you know they're going to go in
and lay out 50 cents or whatever it is
and put it in their mouth and they're
not going to for 50 cents and putting in
your mouth i mean you're not going to
say i'll i'll put in i'll lay out 45
cents and put something else in my mouth
so you find that very stable
and we like businesses that we think we
can figure out where they're going to be
in 10 or 15 years i don't know where the
information technology businesses are
going to be in 10 or 15 years i know
where snickers bars are going to be in
10 or 15 years they're going to be
selling just about this you know the way
they do now i know where wrigley's gum
is going to be in 10 or 15 years there's
not going to be a lot of innovation
in in chewing them
and people the internet's not gonna
cause people to quit chewing gum either
i mean at least i mean gates may think
so but i don't think so
but uh
uh
[Music]
it's
it's predictability
regarding the sustainability of a
competitive advantage some something
special about a product you both have
several managers working under you so i
was wondering what are some steps that a
new entrant into the job market can take
to accelerate their journey towards an
upper
level management position
yeah well one thing i will tell you that
i didn't realize when i was getting out
of school is how much
the unusual person
will jump out at you i mean
you know and it isn't because they got
200 iqs or anything like that it's
really because just how they behave you
know what they bring
the energy they bring the commitment
they bring the quality of how they do
things
how they treat the people around them
all kinds of things but
you will jump out much more than you
might anticipate
one of the things you would want to
be sure to do
is whether you like it or not
get very
comfortable it may take a while with
public speaking for example i mean that
that's a an asset
that will last you 50 or 60 years and
it's a liability if you don't like doing
it or uncomfortable doing it that also
will last you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill
but a lot of the skills are just human
skills
if you get the best out of people around
you
that's a rare talent and it it doesn't
it doesn't correlate with iq it
correlates with a you know an attitude
and uh
toward the world and toward other people
and
it's a talent that if you work at early
and you're really conscious about it you
know you don't have to show up other
people you know you don't have to be
smart in there or anything you want to
bring out the best in them it will pay
huge dividends if you were to do it all
over again you're in our shoes
what industry would that be in where
would you start your own business today
i'd do the same thing yeah i mean
for one thing i'd be a failure to
anything else probably
no i mean i've had i had fun when i was
in my 20s my 30s now i'm 86 and i'm
having fun and so i i advise students as
much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job i mean you know
don't sleep walk through life and don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know i'll do this and i'll do that and
you know i'm just marking time to get to
be older that i've told people that's
like saving up sex for your old age i
mean it just is not
it
it's not a good idea yeah
what are you urging them to do
i'll explain it
guess what i'm talking about that
now
it
you just yeah you really want to be
doing what you love doing and you can't
necessarily find it on your first job
right but don't give up before you find
it it is always being ahead of the game
rather than getting behind the game it's
saving a little no matter how you do it
i mean i delivered papers i worked at
pennies i sold golf balls i had a
pinball machine round i did a lot of
things
that enabled me to accumulate about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school
uh
ten thousand doesn't go as far now as it
did then but it having anything so that
you're ahead of the game and not getting
behind the game
is enormously important i mean just
you know if you're gonna to run 100 yard
dash against a bunch of people in life
if you can figure it out so that when
the gun goes off you're 10 or 15 yards
ahead
instead of 10 or 15 yards behind it's
going to make an enormous difference in
how that race comes out so
having having some net
resources
doesn't make much difference whether
they're in stocks or bonds in my view
but uh
and not having debt
when that gun goes off when you get out
of school
is a huge plus over being behind the
game and
uh
you know
it may come from delivering a paper out
in the morning it may come from
part-time work someplace but
but put aside a few dollars for yourself
but
uh so that when the time comes and you
enter
you enter the workforce uh you're ahead
of the game and not behind and then once
you get there don't get behind by buying
a whole lot of things that you figure
you're going to pay for some day while
you're paying 20 interest in between you
will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh
you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse
i can't overemphasize how important that
is and you're right the friends you have
uh
they will form you as you go
through life and
uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but have them be
people that you admire as well as like
them is there a meaningful distinction
to be drawn between
making money out of investment and
making money out of speculation it's
always a bet isn't it it's always a
gamble no it isn't a gamble there is a
real distinction now basically it it's
subjective but
an investment attitude you look to the
asset itself to produce the return so if
i buy a farm and i expect it to produce
80 an acre for me in terms of its
revenue from corn and soybeans and it
cost me six hundred dollars i'm looking
at the i'm looking at the return from
the farm itself i'm not looking at the
price of the farm every day or every
week or every year the habits you
develop and and i go back the other
thing is have the right heroes i mean
i've always been lucky in that respect
and
if you know if you the people you look
up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life and the one
well i'll give you two pieces of advice
i'd invest as much in myself as you can
i mean you're your own biggest asset by
far i mean you've got you've got all
kinds of potential all the people in
this room you know you're lucky to be in
this country gotten a good education
but
most people go through life using up a
very very small part of their potential
there can be all kinds of wonderful
investment opportunities out there that
i don't understand i don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do next year
you know maybe you know but i don't know
i i don't know what i don't know what uh
crude oil is going to sell for
but
i don't have to know
i just have to know the things i have to
know what i know
i have to know
where the limits of my understanding are
what i call what my circle of confidence
is
and if i'm only able to evaluate five
percent of the businesses in the world
no problem i just stay within that five
percent and try and find something
uh and that's most people get in trouble
because
in investments because they
uh well they get itchy you know they
can't discipline themselves and they
hear about other people making money
nothing upsets people so much as to hear
about their friends making money i mean
it's that that's very destructive to
discipline because they think i'm
smarter than that guy next door and he
just just bought that new car with the
money made trading stocks on the
internet so why can't i
well the answer is you can't over time
you will lose money to trade stocks
actively
and
it's it's hard to exercise the
discipline
but anytime you buy something
you should be able to take out a
one-page sheet of paper
and say i'm buying general motors it's
65 i'm buying general electric 150
because
and you should write down the reasons if
you can't if you can't fill out the
sheet
if it's because somebody told me about
it at a cocktail party last night that's
not good enough if it's because my
broker told me about it that's not good
enough
yeah it's uh you've got to have a reason
for thinking that it makes an
intelligent investment you do the same
thing if you're buying a farm or an
apartment house if you're buying a farm
you'd say i'm buying this farm with a
thousand dollars an acre because i think
i can earn sixty dollars an acre on it
if corn sells it such and such and
soybean cells and such and such and
yield as such and such
and you'd figure it out
that's the same reason you buy
businesses and when you buy stocks
you're buying a little piece of a
business
and that's probably the most important
thing to remember in in investing is
that when you're buying a stock you're
buying a little piece of the business
and if you're buying it at an attractive
price for the business for the whole
business you're going to make money and
if you aren't
you know over time you won't make money
charlie munger and i have been making
stock decisions and business decisions
uh one way or another together
now for 55 years
we have never
let
well the macro doesn't enter into it not
just political we haven't we have not
made decisions differently because one
party or the other is in power we have
not not made decisions based on whether
we thought interest rates were going to
go up or down or or you know what was
going to happen with labor negotiations
someplace
you know you don't want to give up what
you know how to do
because of opinions which you don't know
whether right or not and which are going
to be transitory in any event so you
really go out there every day
and do whatever makes the most sense so
when we buy the auto dealerships last
week uh we don't factor in anything
about the fed about the deadlock and
politics about what's going on around
the world those are all important things
but they don't affect whether those
dealerships which we're buying to own a
hundred years they don't affect whether
they're going to make money in the year
2024 or 2034 or 2044. and the important
thing is whether we get a good business
with good management at a sensible price
it's very important to have the right
framework you need
you need you need to have an approach to
investing that's sound and
graham's approach is is simple
uh but some people
uh
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't um but if you have the
right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years i would follow my passion i
mean whatever turns you on you know i uh
uh i found i was lucky i found something
early that that turned me on but but uh
you don't want to take a job just for
the money you don't want to take a job
for an organization that you really
don't feel good about or work for people
that you don't feel good about you you
really want to be excited when you get
out of bed every morning it won't
necessarily be the job that you have 10
years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along and you know i i took a job with
ben graham my hero and and it you know i
never asked the salary and i found at
the end of the month when i got my first
paycheck what i was earning because i
just knew it was the right thing to be
to be doing so i would i would i would
follow
follow your passion i think you'll learn
more about yourself
if you do it that way i bought my first
stock when i was 11. i was actually i
was at rose hill at the time and i
bought three shares of city service
preferred
at
38 and it went down to 27 which is
something i still remember even though i
was 11 at the time
uh and then it went up to 40 and i sold
it i made five bucks on my three shares
after commissions and then it went to
200 and something so
uh you know i i probably remember that a
little better than if i'd been doing it
on paper
and
i fooled around doing a lot of things
between about age 11 and 19 in the stock
market i did charts i did all kinds of
technical analysis i read every book i
could get on the subject
and
i didn't do that well i didn't do
terrible but but i did i was really just
floundering around
but by
that meant by the age of 19 when i read
ben graham's book i was at the
university of nebraska in lincoln i went
and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me
now if i hadn't done
in the previous eight years if i hadn't
been all over the lot i'm not so sure
that that book would have had the same
impact on me i mean i was by that time i
was prepared
to read ben graham's book which changed
my life financially in an
incredible way i mean
uh
i wouldn't be up here today if i had
read that book but
yeah part of life is getting prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant you can grasp the
significance of it and know what to do
with it and i would say that first eight
years of fooling around
even though it produced nothing
financially to speak of
uh produced a lot in terms of getting my
mind prepared for when i really did read
something that made sense so i was ready
to accept it there are lots of lousy
businesses you know and there's lots of
wonderful businesses
and
my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and i've
made plenty of mistakes i bought a
company called dexter shoes in the early
90s i paid 400 plus million dollars for
it and
it it made a lot of money before i
bought it but you know as soon as i
bought it they pulled some switch or
something and it
immediately started losing money and uh
and it was because of foreign
competition so on there it was maybe
because i owned i don't know
and it went to zero and the worst thing
was that i paid for it in stock so that
400 million in stock i gave at the time
is uh
now worth about 5 billion so it uh
so
every time berkshire stock goes down i
feel a little bit better because of my
opportunity
loss on this business but you know when
i looked at dexter's shoe they had a
good position in retailers they turned
out good shoes they had a great
workforce all kinds of things but
i just forgot one thing that that they
weren't going to make shoes in the
united states anymore
so
you make you make mistakes and it does
pay
to recognize
quickly when you've made them if you've
got a good person running a business and
it isn't making any money
uh
you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and
it doesn't take a high iq to figure out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
that
it yeah i mean i figured out very early
you don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything so
that's my generalized stock tip what are
the key indicators you look for within
companies before making an investment
well i look for something that does give
them a motor rod
we have a company called sea's candy out
on the west coast sea's candies box
chocolates
if you give a box of sea chocolates to
your girlfriend of the first day and she
kisses you
we own you you know we can raise the
price tomorrow i mean you'll buy the
same box you're not going to fool her
out with success so
the key there is the response
you do not want to go home on
valentine's day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart
[Music]
they're the same person you don't say
here honey i took the low bid it doesn't
work
price is
to a degree is immaterial if you've got
a economic castle people are going to
come and want to take that council away
from you and you better have a strong
moat you better have a nightmare castle
that knows what he's doing if you tell
me who your heroes are i can tell you
how you're going to turn up to quite an
extent
by this point in life and i i i have
been extraordinarily lucky
and that none of my heroes ever let me
down i mean i the ones i uh
came up with
uh throughout their lives uh that i've
never felt that i've been let down in
any way with it number one was my dad
and and uh
had a huge impression on me uh um my
wife who is heroes is one of my heroes i
mean she is uh
you know in terms of of uh she's taught
me a tremendous amount and then and
never seen anybody any better with human
beings than
she is and
you can you know yogi bear again said
you can you can observe a lot just by
watching and uh
i uh you know i i watched my dad and i
watched her and
i had a professor ben graham uh back at
columbia and had a huge impact on me so
i have been lucky in that i've had
terrific heroes and they they haven't
let me down and and
that
that takes you a long long way i've gone
through one or two periods where we're
kind of tough in life but
not any i mean every everybody's had had
that but but having the right heroes
will take you right through it you
haven't bought the stock you're an
admirer of jeff bezos a listing of the
richest people in america came out he's
number one i think your friend bill
gates is number two you're number three
so you can see what he's done in myriad
ways
and of course the question is
how come you haven't bought amazon is
there still time to buy would you still
buy it well i i always admired
jeff i mean i met him 20 years ago or so
and and
and
i thought he was something special but i
didn't realize you could go from books
to what what's happened there no i i
mean he had a vision and executed in an
incredible way
something that
it would not have
you know that
but there's a lot of games i miss i
would have missed you know i would have
missed microsoft even if i gotten to
know bill
earlier or something those just aren't
my games i don't worry about the things
that i miss that are outside my circle
of competence
of evaluating i i do i have missed
things that were within my circle
and that's a terrible mistake those are
my biggest mistakes you haven't seen
them
and but i don't
it's not a mistake because i miss
netscape or something like that at all
i would say that maybe five percent of
the companies or ten percent of the
companies at most are within an area my
circle of confidence there's something i
shouldn't be able to understand warren
is probably the most rational person
i've ever met charlie munger would be a
close rival
and charlie became a man that warren
depended on heavily
and i think his first experiences in the
discarded cigar but era convinced him
that it was not exactly where he wanted
to be
he'd made so much money for so long
doing what he'd been taught by ben
graham we should buy these very cheap
stocks and if they were cheap enough he
didn't care it was a lousy company and a
lousy management he knew he was going to
make money anyway just because of the
cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices rather than
fair companies at wonderful prices and
that was enormously important because it
enabled berkshire to scale up in a way
that would have been impossible to do
otherwise we were metal partners right
from the moment we met
i want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first met warren
well i thought he was a prodigy
and i got a lot of criticism my wife
said why are you paying such enormous
respect to that young man with a crew
cut who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into just a
very few words
if you're not interested in the economic
scene right now
you're mentally dead charlie has no tax
all right let's talk a little bit about
bankers charlie on friday compared them
to heroin addicts yeah well that's
colorful charlie but i would not have
chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility
he didn't get his fair share
the ideal way to run a headquarters is
to have one man
preferably over 80 sitting in an office
by himself
[Music]
anything else is pure fruitery
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listened to him
we never had an argument
we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what the hell difference does it make to
me
net the record is working out fine how
do i value the business as berkshire
acquires well the first thing i have to
decide when somebody calls me
is is valuing this business within my
circle of competence
i don't know how to value microsoft i
don't know how to value oracle i mean if
you know larry ellison calls me or bill
gates calls me and they don't but if any
of those i don't know
or biotech or anything i wouldn't know
how to value it i just you know i'd wish
them well and tell them you know i think
it's worth twice as much as they think
it is but i'm just not in the mood to
buy today uh i i don't know so it has to
be within my circle of confidence
my circle of confidence you know
businesses i can understand and when i
say understand
i don't mean to understand how to use a
computer and not use a computer in terms
of a computer company i mean understand
what the economic characteristics of the
business are and what the company's
really going to look like in five or 10
or 20 years
bill gates will tell you that that he
you know if he were investing he would
buy berkshire rather than microsoft
because
it's so much easier to understand what
our businesses are going to look like
whereas he's in a business where you're
going to really have to be doing things
differently over time so i know that
wrigley's going to be the number one
chewing gum in the country i know
stickers are going to be the number one
candy bar in the country 10 years from
now it's been the number one candy bar
for 40 years
you don't have to be
very bright to understand that when
people lay out 50 cents for something
that they stick in their mouth that
they're not about to experiment you know
i mean it's so
we we try to look at businesses we can
understand if you buy a business if you
buy a farm you know you go up and look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for i've
got one farm that i bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
i've been there once you know i mean it
it it doesn't grow faster if i go and
stare at it you know i can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and i know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and someone prices
aren't going to be good i know there's
years when yields will be better than
others
but about the farm and and uh
if
it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions on it or anything
of the sort i do care that over
over the years it's well tended to in
terms of rotating crops and i hope
yields get better which they generally
have
in fact
that farm
100 years ago would have probably
produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices go
back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better at
whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or
soybeans or all kinds of things
and you and i have benefited from that
and so apple is kind of like a farm
well it's a it's a long term investment
and and
if you owned
if you own the the best auto dealership
in town uh the best brand and had
something
good running you wouldn't drop by every
day and say you know how many people
have come in today or you know i think
interest rates are going up a little
maybe that'll slow down our sales or
anything no
you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and you're going to own it for 20
years so that's 7 300 days and you know
they're gonna things are going to be
different from day to day and year to
year you shouldn't buy it if the
day-to-day stuff is important both of us
know
that we've done better by having
ethics
warren's not interested in making money
by cheating people
warren's opinions of wall street
investment bankers would not endear him
to their mothers
he feels that they're for the most part
not out for their clients
they're out for their own business
interests
in the late 1960s there were just a
flood of accounting shenanigans and
mergers built upon false accounting and
misleading people
it was a time when a lot of charlatans
were prevailing in wall street and were
being applauded by wall street and i
understood what the game was about but i
didn't want to play in it
so i closed down the partnership at the
end of 1969
and i took on the title of chairman for
the berkshire hathaway the question is
about the personal qualities we look for
in the in the executives we place at our
various companies
the first thing is we don't usually
place them i mean they come with them uh
we don't have anybody to place so
i have the problem occasionally if
somebody dies or uh to
replace uh a ceo
but
most of our ceos came with the deal
clayton holmes which we're buying comes
with kevin clayton right running it we
will put no one in there
he will run the place just as before
but in terms of the personal quality
when when a when a seller comes to me
with a business
whether it's clayton or any of those and
the others ike friedman at borsheims uh
mrs b at nebraska furniture mart when
they come to me the first question i
have to ask myself because i'm counting
on them to run the place
i have to decide what do they love the
money or do they love the business
now there's nothing wrong with liking
the money i mean they all like money but
but they've got to love the business
they got to have a passion for it
because if i give them a whole bunch of
money and they love the money and they
don't love the business
no matter what they tell me six months
from now they'll be gone you know i mean
they'll just all of a sudden say why am
i getting up at seven in the morning
just so i can send a lot of money to
omaha you know i mean it it just
it won't work so they have to love the
business i mean i want people with a
passion for the business i used to say
that i had a one-line
employment form one question employment
form the question was are you a fanatic
you know if you answered yes you got the
job because i want somebody's fanatic
about their business you have over a
hundred billion dollars of cash
berkshire does that work
berkshire has over 100 billion in cash
and you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress
so how much cash should an ordinary
investor have on a percentage basis do
you think it depends on their personal
situation i mean it
uh
if
if
if you're working in something where
you're you're living off your
your your paycheck
from week to week
you want to have a little cash around
and and you certainly don't want to have
a credit card that's maxed out or
anything like that the worst investment
i ever made
how long do you have
[Applause]
well i i've made some very bad ones but
that doesn't really bother me i you know
it may bother the shareholders but
that's another question
the uh
you know you're gonna make you're gonna
make mistakes in life i mean there's no
question about it you don't wanna make
them on the big decisions you know who
you marry and some things like that so
there's no way i'm going to make a lot
of business and investment decisions
without making some mistakes i may try
to minimize them
i i don't i don't dwell on them at all i
don't i don't look back
the biggest mistakes
are the ones that actually don't show up
they're the mistakes of omission rather
than commission we've never lost that
much money
on any one investment uh
but it's the things that i knew enough
to do that i didn't do we have we have
missed profits
of as much as you know maybe 10 billion
dollars in things that i knew enough to
do and i didn't do now the fact i didn't
buy microsoft way back
uh is not a foregone opportunity because
i didn't know enough to make that
decision but there have been other
investments where i didn't know enough
to make the decision
and for one reason or another i either
didn't do it at all or i did it on a
small scale i was sucking my thumb when
i should have been writing checks you
know basically
and and you know those don't show up
there's no place where it shows missed
opportunities but i've i've missed some
big ones the triumphs in life
are are partly triumphs because you know
that everything isn't going to be a
triumph and and
i would never get too hung up
on mistakes i know a lot of people that
really agonize over them and it it just
isn't worth it i mean tomorrow's another
day and you live it forward and just go
on to the next thing i would encourage
you if you're interested in the field
uh
to
to do a few things i'm still trying to
make it as intelligent as possible i
would try to stick with things
businesses i thought i understood i'd
still get out that sheet of paper and
i'd write i'm doing this because
and just test my reasoning then i go
back and read it a year later and and
see whether what you thought would be
true turned out to be true so i would
always check myself i believe in grading
myself on everything you know doctors
have post mortems and they they do it
because they learn from postmortems uh
and business people don't like to do
postmortems when i'm i'm i can be on the
board of a company and they can
owners building plants or buying
companies and they never wanted two
years later to run a check on how that
decision turned out because it it can be
unpleasant
but you learn from postmortems
and uh you don't want to learn it's way
better to learn from other people's
mistakes than your own but you got to
learn from a few of your own too and
the time to do it is when you're young
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there